Speaking from a culture that's very much more superstitious, and about,
in this case, I feel like I hear a lot
of people in the younger generations who believe that's great.
Now we can find out different things, whereas with the
older generations, I feel like we hear a lot of,
you should never play with that kind of stuff, you
don't know what's going to happen. And even though it
just in this case testing it leads to trying to
fix things, or trying to change things in order to stop.
You know, you, you don't know where it's going to go, from here.
>> Sure.
>> For sure. Definitely we don't know.
>> I that the public sort of understanding of this sort of genetic
information is sort of twofold. I think
one, there's sort of this science fictiony
sort of portrayal of of, this will be the end golice, this will be
some of answers, like you will, you will find the outlet. Are you going to
develop Alzheimer's, not sort of the understanding
of probability. So I think there's a lot
of stock in this information that may not
have come to fruition yet, scientifically. I think
the other end of it, is there is a lot of mystery, and a lot of mysticism behind
it, and a lot of you know, curiosity, and and just lack of understanding.
>> Carol,
you were going to say something too?
>> I had seen an article written by a medical ethicist it
just was very coincidental. And his
point of view is that people like us, should not have
access to genetic information, and this is up to the physicians.
>> So people like us,
[CROSSTALK]
is just the general public?
>> Yeah, the general public. And I debated him on this issue
and it, it I think
that in the medical community and in, and in probably in
education, where people are sitting in their ivory tower.
They think that the general public shouldn't have access to this information,
and I think that sells people short. Particularly
today, where in the age of the computer, age
where everything is on Facebook and on Twitter.
And, I mean it, it's open. People want to know. And I think that
it's going to change radically.
>> I think part of what Strong was saying
about, there's the two sides of it. People think, put
too much stock in it, or there's this strange
you know, misunderstanding or mysticism about it. Is the fact
that this kind of availability of information, is so
new. I mean 23andMe just about eight years ago, cost
$1,000. And now it's under 100. And so it's
only now, that we're starting to, it's only now available,
to the general public. And there's questions of,
should the general public be allowed to have
this information. In the state of, where I'm
from, in Maryland, 23andMe is illegal. You cannot.
>> It is illegal?
>> You cannot, 23andMe will not ship to Maryland, or New York.
>> Really.
>> Because the state has passed that
genetic information, can only come from a doctor.